[Musik]
das hat deutlich gemacht
es gibt auf youtube wirklich sehr sehr
viele youtuber die einfach gestoppt
werden müssen und da habe ich damals
schon mal videos zu gemacht hier ging es
beispielsweise um einem youtuber gegen
den angeblich ein mordanschlag
durchgeführt werden sollte und er hat
sich wunde ins gesicht gemalt
hier habe ich gesagt das heim in der
früh gestoppt werden muss da sein video
gefällt war doch heute meine damen und
herren packen ich brauch erst mal ganz
kurz meine brille letzten videos in
denen ich auf youtube reagiert habe die
gestoppt werden müssten
die sind drei beziehungsweise vier
monate her heute geht es allerdings nur
ein youtuber beziehungsweise um das
video eines youtube stars naja es das
ist schon ein jahr alt also es ist jetzt
kein aktuelles thema ist jetzt kein
aktuelles video auf dass ich mich jetzt
hier bezieher es ist allerdings ein
youtuber der regel richtig hochleben und
wirklich einer der größten youtuber in
deutschland ist tatsächlich keiner weiß
was eigentlich genau warum und zwar
heißt dieses video der beste blocker
aller zeiten das video hat eine
millionen 72 1456 aufrufe und die
bewertungen sind tatsächlich recht
positiv aber lasst euch von diesem
schein nicht trügen die dabei ist dass
das ich luca die besten blogs mache dies
überhaupt auf youtube gibt aber ich will
jetzt gar nicht mehr lange hier um den
heißen brei drumrum schnacken
ich würde sagen wir stützen uns mal
direkt in diesem blog der hier betitelt
wird als bester blocker zeit
jeder weiß dass das gelogen ist egal
dieser youtuber redet wie eine
abgehackte banane
bäume hast du noch nie bäume gesehen
oder was das video geht hier gerade drei
sekunden und ich musste schon zweimal
stoppen aber wir schauen jetzt mal ab
der stelle ok
was ist das bitte für ein fetter pickel
wie kann er sich überhaupt trauen ein
video aufzunehmen mit so einem fetten
monströsen pickel bist du komplett
geisteskrank alter wir sitzen im auto
auf dem weg nach amsterdam und neben uns
steht die übelste ps maschine
es ist ein trecker
es war das regal
passt auch noch meine depping musik oder
was
möchtest du vielleicht noch mehr an den
pickeln zoomen
muss ich da noch irgendwas zu sagen wir
sehen uns wieder bei mir in ampere dame
angekommen und ich suche jetzt extra
offen in dickeren
[Musik]
wie kann ein mensch so
wir müssen noch einen kumpel abholen da
ist hier irgendwo auf dem parkplatz des
liegen meldet jetzt mal tommy wo bist du
ruby gehabt jetzt alleine toni
warum rufst du nicht einfach an noch
etwas länger reichen nur wenige minuten
später sowie noch immer nicht gefunden
aber wir haben hier gerade was auf
überhaupt nächsten
[Musik]
aber wie will mich dieser typ wenn ich
noch nachmachen in etwa gleiche frisur
gleicher blogging stil macht jetzt auch
noch ihr dj mixes
wir schauen
ich habe mir noch ein balkon und man
kann quasi komplett über amsterdam
du hast noch nie etwas über airbnb
gebucht in welchem jahr lebt dieser
youtube
1804 wenn die bude
was ist das für ein herzlicher mensch
wie kann dieser youtuber mit solchen
leuten befreundet sein alter erst findet
er die nicht auf dem parkplatz und jetzt
ist er angekommen und
ich würde sagen guck mal wie viele
abonnenten dieser youtuber hat ein paar
sekunden später 2,8 millionen und fast
eine milliarde videoabrufe aha ist bis
jetzt ein star oder was gott ich diese
ganzen youtuber hasse mit ihren videos
da bist du nicht das bin ich
[Musik]
müssen wir da noch irgendetwas zu sagen
30 egal was hat er eigentlich für haare
wird sie die maschinen alle waren schon
duschen ich sehe aus wie eine lampe
alles klar
ich bin ich weil ich keine ahnung wieso
ihr euch das an
ja ich habe auch keine ahnung wie soll
ich mir das gerade an druck und du
solltest auf jeden fall gestoppt werden
jetzt hat er auch noch meine
was diese steht hier herrscht
beste freunde mit ich habe hier eher
gediegen jetzt auch mal meine pimpernel
neff links hier im volk mit
das ist hier da kann man hier nicht mehr
einfach hier mal ein auge zudrücken
das ist ganz ganz ganz ganz untere
schublade ist passiert
wir sind in der stadt angekommen also
was heißt angekommen wir sind eigentlich
nur aus der tür raus gegangen haben uns
alle für interessierte wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr um einen kanal abonnieren also
einfach ihnen wirklich wisst ihr wenn er
wenigstens nur scheiß videos machen
würde wäre es ja noch in ordnung aber er
sagt zu dem die ganze zeit mann soll
seinen kanal abonnieren man sollen
leichter lassen man sollte ihnen das in
die kommentare schreiben will hier
engagement haben interaktion mit seinen
zuschauern was welcher depp keiner guckt
sich sowas an wir sehen hier tatsächlich
am rand sogar videos von mir
vorgeschlagen warum warum schlägt
youtube meinen content bei so einem
scheiß nebenan vorher wortspiele
unterwasser challenge besoffen fußball
spielen verstecken die krea hier alles
blogs folgen wir alle über eine million
aufrufe okay er hat auch über eine
million aufrufe auf diesem blog ja aber
es gibt kein schwein aber ich würde
sagen wir schauen wir mal weiter hier
sein flug überhaupt rock nennen kann ist
extra die kamera hier hinten wirklich
jetzt gleich an der kamera vorbei laufen
wo ist das ein spaß die alten
mittagessen besteht kannst du nicht
wechselseitig schnell gehen auch das
ausland moderiert
jetzt micronas vorgeworfen den blogs in
scheiße weil ich einfach nicht locker
top blogger reda
guck mal wie schön damen war wasser
schon mal der himmel blau echt schön
hier so froh dass ich alles machen da
und zum leben leben darf und ganz fix an
bier gekauft
ey
wisst ihr es gibt youtuber da sage ich
noch okay kann man augen zudrücken
machen jetzt nicht zu den allerbesten
content und dann gibt's halt ihn
da auch wenn man zehn augen hat kann man
die nicht alle mehr zudrücken man jetzt
spiele ich für meinen blog ich sehe
meine stütze
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guck mal keiner mag ihn die so hörst du
dich einfach auf wird youtube zu hause
angekommen also das heißt zuhause das
ist also diesem erwin meetings
[Musik]
das hat deutlich gemacht also schlimm
genug kassels gefurzt hat er hat auch
noch seine kamera kann sein
ist sowas überhaupt auf dieser plattform
spieler scheißen geht chips eingebaut
sei auch ruhig alle hassen ihn halt
wirklich so dass einfach die wahrheit
warum sitzt jetzt verdammt noch mal in
der badewanne
die verstehen das nicht
das ist mein leben mit euch teilen
zuschauern druckvoll gerne bereit ist
diese geschichte
es tut mir leid dieses video hier
besteht nur daraus dass ich auf diesen
komischen wie heißt er hier korn after
dass sich auf denen reagiere die er sich
beim kurzen film wie er sich fühlen wie
in einer badewanne sitzt wie er
irgendwelche trecker film wie er sich
film diaby 1 kauft also irgendwie dieses
video macht nicht so viele sind aber
dieser youtuber muss verdammt noch mal
gestoppt werden schreibt mal bitte alle
in die kommentare von crafter muss
gestoppt werden freunde
diese sind fucking hufen geistes gottes
wenn euch dieses video hier gefallen hat
dann lasst vier peace zeichen da oder
einfachen like falls ich mehr youtuber
stoppen soll wenn ihr eventuell videos
von anderen youtube kennt die in letzter
zeit hochgeladen wurden wo ihr euch
einfach gedacht habt hey was das für ein
karg video also so etwas wie der erste
mordanschlag gegen milch oder zwei mit
erst wieder wieder was fällt oder katja
glaser wird die in eigenen song jetzt
raus bringen schreibt mir diese videos
gerne mal und in die kommentare dann
werde ich das nicht mal darauf reagieren
und jetzt meine damen und herren kommt
das worauf alle immer warten alle chance
meine videos an nur das ende zu sehen
also rudi autohändlers was ist ihr vom
video das was jetzt hier vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten mal einen shop
ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ich schon abonnenten
zeit könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken
dann bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]